you're a blessing Mr Clay this place was
crab grass and weeds and you brought it
back to life Mrs Parker and I were
friends she was the only person who ever
took care of any I just got a message
saying that there's a problem with my
computer yes ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three one 1 2
three there I did it for
you now you can't take it I'm going to
burn this place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper that's
not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have laws for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off come on
bro don't
move
bow
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam the money is going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem cut them
right I'm a
problem I figed i' give the firefighters
a break somebody detain this
guy
we have to kill him before he kills his
way to the
top
honey it's flammable oh
know